when we had our first platinum record in
1997 out of nowhere we get a call from
the WWF or WWE now and they say hey man
we want you to make the ring music for
this team called The Oddities and we
were like yeah I remember them do you
know we wrestled
and they were like what are you talking
about and they flew us out there and we
wrestled for Vince McMahon let
me get corny for a minute
because it's true as I can be if you
believe in the seat you know what the
secret is yeah the laws of attraction
the power is a positive thinking let me
tell you something me and Joey from the
time I was probably 14 and he was 11. we
knew we were going to be wrestlers I'm
saying it wasn't even a question I used
to tell in school you want
My Autograph now because you're not
gonna be able to get it and you'll be
bragging you went to school with me
cause I'm gonna be a wrestler you know
and I meant